the alpha dog's been debunked this is
fascinating oh let's get into this kick
this down I want to talk about this
Google this right now we'll get the
heart details that dog has been debunked
by the person who invented alpha dog so
it was a guy who followed a pack of
wolves around the quarterback at my high
school yeah
Johnny Johnny Q-tip
[Laughter]
oh [__] and then he threw a spiral
perfect okay we think it's true Johnny
he threw it at the sun and it was so
hard and so far that after 28 minutes we
heard a small Sizzle he hit the Sun and
made sound travel through a vacuum
he's that good folks actually what we
were hearing was someone else who threw
a fall of the sun seven years earlier
isn't that how long it takes it's not
seven years oh what for Life For Life to
get eight minutes eight minutes okay all
right
um I got it seven years
I thought if the sun burned out would
would still have good light for seven
years don't worry everybody but think
about those eight minutes think about
those eight minutes right when the sun
burns out and then there's eight minutes
where everything's fine yeah and you
just listen to Carly Simon is it Like
You Don't Know What You Got Till It's
Gone and then it just fade down battles
that's scary so Alpha Dog yeah so the
guy he followed around this pack of
wolves and he noticed that there was
this one wolf a male wolf that everyone
deferred to this is when he made up the
theory right yeah and so then he wrote
this book and I think the book is called
Alpha Dog
the next year when he went back to study
the same wolf pack he figured it out
that it wasn't they're not just
unrelated individuals that that was the
dad
so it was a family structure and it's
not a social structure and there is no
social Alpha Dog in a wolf pack it's
always familial and oftentimes it's a
female
um and so like
sometimes
and then just no one read it no one read
it people were like Alpha Dog we alpha
dog took off like he was on TV shows
immediately yes people were like yes we
this alpha dog thing we're behind and
then he came out the next year one year
later and was like guys it's wrong it's
wrong Alpha dog's not a thing and people
were like [__] off it's a thing the man
who made Alpha Dog
and it's been like his like commute is
Mikey
thank you so much the guy who told us
the true thing
that justifies you getting beat up by
the quarter and being an [__] of a
boss because you have to be like a wolf
for some reason
they feed the mic up just for him to say
my name's not Jim it's Jim it's Jim
jiminer my whole life I've been called
Jim uh isn't that fascinating it is
fascinating but immediately I go to can
we get a structure of wolves that aren't
related and see what happens I don't
know
first one's called Alpha Dog second
one's called whoops no Alpha third
double whoops should have found a group
of non-related dogs no the third one's
called getting these dogs together yeah
who who indeed let the dogs out I'd like
to know that guy devoted his life to
knowing who let the dogs out yeah for
real because who led them
oh yeah
[Music]